have you ever seen that chimp with no
hair on it they're the most terrifying
Oscars and he goes if he goes that
exists I go yeah he goes what are you
doing did took me into the trees and
they were playing catch with me what how
did you get that's what I brought up
that's what I brought up yes they're
nine times four are they have nine times
more of the bone density than we do yeah
oh there you go their ratio of like
adrenaline ours at the most goes from
like zero to one there's goes from like
zero to 11 oh so they that's why and
they're stronger than so that's why you
a chimpanzee can drop three stories from
on to cement and just walk it off what
yeah that's how strong you know you're
if they rip your I had to work with them
in a movie and I said I want to learn
something beforehand oh really I went
down at the LA Zoo and they said okay
you're gonna work with these guys just
never turn your back on stage and he
said what never turn your back and I
said just don't ever turn your back on
me said why and he did this to me well I
said up and see that guy right there but
taken Karen for 18 18 18 years I've been
you know wiping his ass giving him food
every day I turned my back at him one
time he did this to me and he looked up
and he's missing a finger oh bit my
finger off then there's a guy what area
is there there that's a picture I
brought up man that's our that's it that
was the animal back like 19 so anyways
enjoy that enjoy that look at those
hands built for cruelty just bill to rip
you to shreds
yes that's good there's another thing
there's another guy who's working with
said I was work with a chimpanzee you
can only work with them until they
become like get their incisors and
become like adults because you can't
work them after that because they want
to take you out that's right the other
guy out so you can only work it so it's
not a good idea to work with wild
animals and I wouldn't do it again no
you don't work with adult chimps no ukb
remember when we're on a high one where
a shooting that comedy show and work
with I work with Louie who was the the
orangutan and this is his handler who
worked with his chimpanzee and he told
me this story he said well let me tell
this one story he says so I was with
this you know chimpanzee and he was like
you know 10 Lincoln not quite 11 years
old and he liked to ride in the car in
my pickup truck on my shoulders and he
said then I'm driving we're driving back
to the you know the place and then all
of a sudden I felt this warm liquid
rolling coming down my my neck into my
chest and I look over and it's blood and
I go
and he you bit my ear off so he said it
was everything I could do he's like my
elbow I said he's my elbow I was
punching him as hard as I could go
screaming punching and punching and that
barely was able to get out and I had to
keep the door closed because he would
have come out if he would have got out I
rarely able to well he would have ripped
somebody else's face do you know that JD
who was on like ripped her face off
Delia was on Maury she was sleeping with
this literally sleeping with him in a
ropes you give him like xanax oh yeah
and wine oh I'm sorry
stem glasses with red wine taking baths
with him and then like reading to him I
give him present one day she has like a
guy friend coming like no gasps the
kalam Inger so I was a gal no it was a
guy no it was a woman guy he's a woman
she changed and what happened was she
changed he was a 200-pound mailchimp
great joyful full fully grown fully girl
he had she had changed her hairstyles I
did when I got her hair done and that
chimp star and went I'm gonna eat your
face no remember he ripped her face
that's what they do first is this is I
it's like a fight he said well I'm gonna
do things so first of all I'm gonna bite
off I'm gonna bite off all your fingers
so you don't have a chance to poke my
eye out for a second and then I'm gonna
bite off then I'm gonna take off your
jaw so you can't bite me back and then
I'm gonna bite off your nuts so you know
this is serious that's literally what
they do
cuz the John faith is like I said the
John face didn't do it the nuts didn't
do it they need to be like hey at that
point but champ wins yeah let's jump a
second let's fight very surface
unbelievable well there's that great
show fatal attraction or fatal
attraction on the animal planet or one
of those which says it these idiots that
take a wild animals to say I'm gonna
live with a snake python and is that
Unni loves me he's sleeping next to me
the pythons sleep he's also stretching
all the way he's like he's measuring you
to [ __ ] eat you look exactly what he's
doing Tom tell me what he's doing
somebody had like a komodo dragon you
know and every day he was like he'd lick
me lick me and he pulls please poisoning
you poisoning you slowly and then
eventually ate him and kill the guy you
got to watch the show fatal tracks you
never seen it no I know what you're
gonna do you're gonna watch this and
then you're gonna stay up till five
o'clock in the morning you're not gonna
be able stop watching
that stuff fatal attraction feel bad for
those attacked by that chimp and she
know she can what's not she came to see
she came to see her friend so as the
older tooth has that well know as the
chip is heating the just the latest
landlady I check this out as the chimp
is eating killing her she stabbed him
with a knife and he looked the owner yes
yes because what do you do then the cop
got shot that chimp three times in the
chest and the chimp still climbed up on
top of the roof and then then then they
unloaded on him a bunch of other times
and he finally died with three slugs
from a from a 9-millimeter and the chimp
was like I'm good I'm gonna climb this
I'm gonna climb I'm still gonna climb
the [ __ ] house
yeah no no this you're a touch moans I
beheld a chimp ladies chimp they're made
of wood their muscles are wooden now i
remember cuz this one guy was one you
know nine-year-old orangutan he was
working with in that movie the animal he
was like the first day he like me guy
was a new thing the second thing he was
bored of me already
and i remember cuz yeah this one scene
is his hand around my throat and he was
just like literally like his hand was
like iron and he just started squeezing
my throat am i gonna [ __ ] die right
now probably yeah I don't like primates
well no it's they just it's another
level and like you have to like push me
up I'm telling you they're bone
densities nine times more than us but
it's the exact room density is nine
times nine seven and the adrenaline
level can go up I think it's eleven
times more than us so so that like you
know the fight-or-flight yeah yeah so
they're fine so we combined that bone
density and that muscular you know and
dry right and you combine that with like
this this is like you know this is
something that's swinging on vines and
trees I mean I don't think of thing
about a two hundred or you know two
hundred pound male chimp like what that
would do to you well there's also like
there's four hundred pounds in the congo
sir yeah big boys in the congo yeah they
call them two leopard you don't see one
living on the grill i don't look them in
the eye when you go out to my friend did
i do i do you guys
the baboon that that talks not to look
him in the eye my friend went out there
yeah don't look him in the eye my friend
went out there it's like I just be
called Rhodesia what's the country now
again it's a boy okay you say so he went
out there and you could go out there and
they're these Plains gorillas they're
out in the you know and so it's like the
last group of them left and they people
visitors go out then you pay money which
is great because instead of these guys
who would normally be killing these
beautiful mountains olan mountain laurel
israel yeah yes you could do a tour and
it actually pays for the park pays to
maintain and pays to protect these
animals and so it's it's really a good
thing to go do when you go out there
they tell you there's certain behavior
you do not do you don't stare
you know the silverback yeah yeah don't
[ __ ] with this silver but I'm not going
on that tour they all just give you the
moment here's things over back ain't
here enough but here's communication you
said you go out they said what I said my
friend chattels night he said he went
out there you know he said that so what
do you do is well you know they don't
look him in the eye and you sit down and
you just let him know you're okay and
they tell them there's an mmm-hmm it's
like I'm just everything's cool and
he'll give it back to you you ever see
that video where that where the mountain
gorillas the big male just walks by the
one of the guides and grabs him by the
ankle and just takes them for a little
dragged you see that bring that up
mountain lie Matan grellus oh they did
they're watching the troop in the Congo
there are there all these naturalist and
they're on there it's like you can pay
to do this and you're all like this
they're all staying there they're really
quiet and this giant male comes walking
by grabs the [ __ ] by by his
Hankel and just takes him for a little
driver on be with the head huh well
that's the thing it's like what really
grabs the man out of nowhere
if you just go in done maybe the problem
of people in California is they don't
really realize that there's another rest
of the country out there that's why you
get your Debra Messing's and stuff is
like it is another country out there and
it's like you leave 45 minutes outside
any big city it gets a little weird and
like you have this look whoa
what is it like a napping now he's lying
down try to be cool yeah that's what you
do it's like hey man whoa
but like you like there for instance you
probably don't know this but there are
5,000 lions it privately owned by people
in the United States [ __ ] love and
how much you know but yeah oh [ __ ] well
why'd you ask me it's a terrible lie to
mind because they outgrow just like you
know when you used to have like people
used to have like little turtles which
like have like hepatitis A in there I
know you're anxious yeah you know but we
had them all over the tent turtles and
stuff and then you know some places
they'll get like you can buy an
alligator you know you have an alligator
nobs it gets too big let's get rid of
this damn alligator where are the
problems in the 70s and before they pass
it you could buy Nile crocodiles for
like just he had to goes through three
hoops and buy them so Tommy's in Florida
would have here's a cry now right now
all of a sudden is now crocodile gets to
be not more than five feet and it'll
it'll bite everything don't think I
let's put in the Everglades
they have a problem Columbia right
because well as far had like hippos and
nothing like real crocodile but I have
this now in the Everglades they have
like Burmese pythons yeah you try to
sneak in like a lemon or an orange into
that they look a little cast you'll
they'll tackle you at the airport yeah
but if you tried you say what are you
got in the bag there it is that what is
that a is that Burmese python all right
bring it in just make sure it [ __ ]
everything out there so what happened
was during Hurricane Andrew was when
that you know people just abandoned
their homes and the roofs got blown off
and a couple of these Burmese pythons
got out there and each one of those is
able to lay like 200 300 eggs so you
have like a Burmese you put up Burmese
right on edge you're eating alligator
problem yeah look at Bernie's Python
narrator so don't mess with Florida I
don't go into any bodies of water so
here's what you got you got 40-foot
pythons out there that are literally
they'll eat an alligator and then and
then now and then the alligator will rip
it and explode it so these are like it's
incredible it's not these two animals
are never supposed to meet
well they got Nile crocodiles they think
they're in their water from Florida
because they got they got loose handlers
couldn't take care of them and just let
them loose in the Everglades Wow and
they have had and if you can look it up
they have found some Nile
Salty's
in the Everglades that's a disaster
nightmare dangerous is a danger look at
that right there it's unbelievable so
they go hunting now you can get like a
tag and you can go Python hunting it's
out in the Everglades it's gonna cool I
mean I won't feel bad about that at all
I'm not under those but like if you're
gonna you know I mean this is that
animal should not be there they have to
get that but depopulate that area look
unbelievable well that's the thing to
Florida Florida is always the weird [ __ ]
happens it's in Florida you know some
weird it's always in Florida no guy
who's you know the homeless guys face
remember that story guy got homeless guy
space eatin yeah you know imagine I felt
sorry for the homeless guys Hayes a
naked guy run it towards me yeah you
know it's it what if you curtain what is
he water I wonder what he wants maybe
he's gonna try to [ __ ] me well whatever
I have been [ __ ] a long time you know
what he get though he's eating my face I
did not see this coming
it's it's coming but because Florida
because look at that yeah I don't know
if that's real all can be real it's not
I don't know but it's still a good
picture I'm glad somebody took the time
to do that that's like a whole lot to
ever did that
definitely photocell either ladies right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]